uh i do think it's time mike to
to really some drugs no to call in the
big guns
about this situation now
look say what you want about rogan and
we will
right now yeah no i'm kidding rogan has
a lot of people that unders
you know after this situation rogan
probably had somebody on that really
understands this you know
of course yeah somebody that's like high
level like
some finance access to these guys they
could get a good
maybe yeah maybe he got the dude that
they based a big short off of like
that'd be a really good get right right
now like that guy be
[ __ ] explaining stuff yeah michael
berry or what about uh maybe a zoom
meeting with martin shkreli from jail
yeah so anybody gets it he'd be like oh
if anybody knows financial malfeasance
it's me look so here's what they did
so you so you're going to see you're
going to love this they never
call for regulation ever he's super
souls like him
oh wait a second who is that said eddie
bravo no no no no no no
super souls like him no no no no sir
what's what is it no no no no sir he's
training rocky mike
he's training that hat makes me furious
like like like in irrational anger when
you're when you're
you know you know it's like you ever
have somebody that you're like god
[ __ ] hate that guy and
people have to tell you like dude you
don't even really know him like i don't
know why you ate like
that that hat would make me just hate a
person and it would never be repairable
i'm gonna full screen it really quick
just so people could see it i just would
like did go like what
like that guy forevermore would be known
as the dude with the hat
like you met my boyfriend brandon right
i'd be like is it the guy with the
[ __ ] hat
that guy him the last thing that guy
wants
in terms of like being able to
manipulate the market and make as much
money as possible it's [ __ ]
regulation yeah
so he's calling for regulation i like to
chop he's just saying yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's kind of hilarious and him saying
that they're manipulating it with social
media like
this is literally what they do yep it's
what they do
yeah yep yeah keep going yeah yep you go
there's no interesting things happening
that seem to be spawned to some extent
or at least
at least blown out of proportion by
social media again adina
well i i do think though that as we look
at these new technologies that are there
available
notice something new with rogan's new
setup he's now actually playing the
videos
on the screen he wasn't doing that
before he's getting all his money from
spotify now he doesn't no he doesn't
care about all those
yellow buttons to everyone including
investors
i i think it's also important for
regulators to understand that
you know the skeleton manipulation
whether it's happening through
a new technology medium or it's
happening through traditional mail
i think it's just a matter of making
sure that we understand i just made the
same observation
there you go congratulations shop but no
he is right i know what her i know what
her entire skull looks like
that's not that shouldn't be a thing and
what the behavior is what's underpinning
the behavior and working
i already said that we're not we're not
using underpinning anymore okay that's
another one of those things we're done
using that can we still use unpack
no no unpack no underpinnings let's hack
it for a little bit
i'll think about it appropriately with
the regulators too to uh
to manage the situation she looks like a
female version of
the blind scientist from contact with
jody foster
very it's a little too specific a little
too specific
very specific and also a movie that's
like you know
people kind of remember well he just
rewatched it because remember he had he
had he interviewed
mcconaughey on yeah tell me she doesn't
pull up an image of that guy jamie oh
pull up an image of this chick so me and
my comic genius friend can
riff we're gonna do some riffing
you ready you ready for these [ __ ]
it's the riff it's riff
people on the on this clip have issues
he has richard ramirez teeth
it's a nightmare contact who's richard
ramirez the night stalker
oh okay contact with jody foster
go to images yeah i think jamie could
[ __ ] navigate google images
all right jamie click on all right click
on the windows logo
and click on it's gonna say google
chrome open that up
and then hit delete and then install
brave
the guy in the far right yeah oh a
little bit
come on give me that picture yeah i'll
give you that the guy in the far right
hello joe we're calling them now
even people on the right side of the
screen now are near
i don't like that they're [ __ ] taking
our taking our whole gimmick by watching
videos and making fun of them it kind of
bothers me i hate that table
i i hate honestly
that that whole studio for the money he
has
it's like it's embarrassing it's a
shitty studio
i don't mean to dead name or misgender
okay keep playing it
working appropriately with the
regulators too to uh to manage the
situation
yeah you heard that correctly the guy
from cnbc who hates regulation is now
calling for more regulation
wait so we're watching a video
of a guy walking out no no no no no even
bought it he's better than that watching
a video of two guys
watching a video of a guy watching a
video
this is they're watching us watch that
holy [ __ ] bro this is meta dude
crazy dude bro like hey jamie like what
if you gave a monkey lsd
how cool would that be i quit okay
i won't do this anymore [ __ ] hate you
joe one day they're gonna pan over
to jamie again and it's just gonna be
like the end of psycho it's just gonna
be a skeleton
just sitting there just a [ __ ]
skeleton in the chair
and the ceo of the head of one of the
largest trading exchanges
in the world is that you can close your
eyes this guy sounds like gut felt
yeah he does yeah it's very weird he's
the one that does the show with crystal
ball
oh this is that guy yeah notice when
hedge funds manipulate markets
when they screw over regular people in
different companies
wall street requires billions sorry can
your dad yeah please can your dad please
come out here you just get me somebody
who looks like they're older than
19. who perhaps
more than any president is responsible
for much of the financialization of our
economy
beginning in his administration levitt
wrote an op-ed in bloomberg
calling for a full agency investigation
into online stock trading platforms
and said that social media is taking
advantage of users behavioral psychology
and pushing them into dangerous
territory okay
maybe i don't even really disagree with
that but doesn't it just tell you
everything that this is what they want
to investigate now
i'm sorry i thought this was going to be
more of a shop clip but it turned out to
be just them watching the hill we're
just going to watch this
i guess we're just just them just them
watching the
like if that if i if i were the hill i
would actually be annoyed
i'd be like wow you know i mean i get
fair use but like
you just posted a whole clip up there
and didn't even provide commentary
well i think rogan's had this guy on his
show come on rogan learn how to do fair
use right yeah hey hey rogan you've been
on the internet you've been on the
internet long enough you should be able
to figure this out
uh let me see something here because uh
it's with this is on his chair okay
powerful oh this is the powerful j
so his clip channel is j hold on uh hold
on a second
so his clip channel used to do this
stuff but now
these clips he's on spotify he's just
posting clips on his main channel now
because it has more subs
yeah it makes sense yeah yeah yeah yeah
um
look one more quick thing with them
because because somebody told me we had
to watch this
uh this is job and uh and bro and rogan
talking about dave chappelle and kovitz
i think you're going to like this
theater okay stubbs has a 400 seat
amphitheater
and uh so we tested the entire crowd and
then
um someone in dave's circle not related
to the show got coveted and was hanging
around with david you tested the entire
crowd for a show
oh my god that sounds terrible imagine
getting tested to see joe rogan
yeah well he might he may help a stool
i i wouldn't like there there are i'm
trying to think there are some really
like
epic events that i probably wouldn't
even bother getting tested for but i'm
like yeah you make me get tested for a
[ __ ]
i don't even want to be here dave
got dave's sick i wouldn't get tested if
the guy on his shirt came back to do
with set
got three or four other people sick
radio raheem got sick
who um do the right thing
the photographer's son got sick i don't
know if the photographer got sick a lot
of guys got sick did you
get it no no elon already had it okay
elon had it in the past and a lot of
people were saying that his
girlfriend grimes gave it to dave that's
not true no it was another guy
or grimy as she liked to be called i
came to dave
his girlfriend grimes had gotten over it
already listen to this
several days listen to this new joe
what do you mean you jump like this like
holding court with oh yeah
so my buddy elon musk oh oh yeah his
girlfriend pops in her grimes
so like she gave to date but she didn't
bro i know these guys
like it's right elitist rogan is like
kind of
weird it just doesn't feel right it's
been getting worse and worse too and i
was like dude so i was like talking on
my pro
neil degrasse tyson right and he was
like yo did you hear about grimes did
she give
covid to dave chappelle and i was like
dude the rumors are so silly
dude i'm friends with all those guys
like i'm friends with all those guys i
know
neil never texted me back because he
said he was with a fly honey
days before she got to the show you yeah
you i don't know maybe of the blood type
or you're just
built different where you're just you're
not the guy who's going to get covered
dr shaw i can't wait so somebody
i can't wait until somebody has to get
this clip and then put the always sunny
joe rogan gets covered and i mean i hope
he gets it immediately
like it's only really that funny if he
gets it
like right away right like right away i
need rogan to come out tomorrow and say
i have coveted
and by the way no i don't want any harm
to befall joe rogan and i'm not wishing
harm on him he'll be fine
i just need him to get covered so that
brendan schaub looks like an even bigger
[ __ ] idiot
than he normally does no but you know at
least he's dressed cool
i couldn't put that hat on forget that
he looks like her urban outfitters was a
person
what's he wearing well the jacket in the
shirt is just a jacket and a shirt but
it's the hat that really makes me
obscenely angry no that jacket looks
like it's made out of paper mache
yeah it's american outfitters oh yeah
probably probably about that
i don't know man but i just got a show
we'll see
i was at a show um with uh
sev oh wait who who's he gonna drop who
are we dropping who we dropping
what do we name dropping he was with
he was with the french minister of
finance
and tupac oh yeah he's alive by the way
we hang out all the time you know you
know tupac didn't get covered but his
hologram did
it's crazy isn't that crazy jamie pull
up the tupac hologram
get tim dillon in here
with uh seven by the way do you see the
tim dillon tweet
yes is is he like obsessed is that all
he thinks about is
glenn maxwell is that all he thinks
that's his whole life jesus
talk about a [ __ ] one-note [ __ ]
bull that wound up getting coveted
because i went to the show and uh i
didn't expect that it was going to be
like so covety everybody was just feel
it
out here bro people don't give a [ __ ]
they just go out
but the thing you should see florida
yeah oh i know dude i did a show for new
year's eve i walked out and there's
it was just everyone's together and i
come i'm like
do you guys not get the news like listen
i'm pretty loosey-goosey
but you so pretty i'm pretty
loosey-goosey but this is
they sold tickets to a show and put all
those people in the building
this attitude right here is exactly
when people talk about don't bring your
la [ __ ] to texas
and don't bring your l.a [ __ ] to
florida it's exactly this here
where it's like i'm pretty loosey-goosey
but this is crazy for me
don't bring because remember rogan was
like yeah people are worried man that
i'm gonna change it but now he's already
like oh the show is a little covety for
me
the whole reason you go to places like
florida and
like texas is because of how horrible
california is
i don't care if you were just like um
it's a little crazy in california
you don't get to come to texas and
you're not going to come to florida and
be like
man i'm i'm a little pretty
loosey-goosey but this is kind of
[ __ ] nuts
shut up well yeah it's it's the i
[ __ ] hate him
it's the old like hey man look i got a
pretty wild sense of humor
but like come on yes don't joke about
that and it's like okay then you don't
have a wild sense of humor
listen i'm pretty loosey-goosey but it's
ridiculous and i see a guy making up
with two chicks in the front
i go hey hold on stop do you know each
other like no
i'm like what the [ __ ] you doing man
they're not worried about it no they
don't care man do you know about
uh quercetin and zinc yeah yeah all
those
different medic or different nutrients
yeah for people that didn't listen to
the mark gordon podcast
truck which was of course most of you
yeah because it wasn't kanye or elon
musk
we're not pals with him yeah we're not
friends we didn't watch
[ __ ] grime suck his dick in its
cybertruck
[Music]
because that's the thing he would say we
live in such a weird world
yes i know it's
why are we here why are we doing this
anymore
why are we all alive coleman should just
take us already
oh you know what's better than any cyber
truck any f-150
no better price
[Laughter]
goddamnit they got me god [ __ ] damn
it
that was very funny holy [ __ ] so i'd
recommend you listen to it because it's
actual
peer-reviewed studies on quercetin which
is something called an ionophore
which gets ions into the cells and then
you take that
with zinc has a much higher absorption
rate of zinc and
cool according to fascinating
do you think spotify is like man i'm
really glad we gave this guy 200 million
dollars i wish we were famous enough to
get on rogan
i really want to be the first person in
history to just go jesus christ joe this
is so [ __ ] boring
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] so boring yeah
but the problem is he repre pre-records
everything now so he'd never air it it's
true
so i got coveted right i was like the
canary in the coal mine for comics
well you were there i was the first one
yeah
it seems to me like kind of everybody's
going to get it yeah
at this point in time man yeah be cool
yeah everybody's gonna get it
but you just did a whole thing where you
were pearl clutching over yeah you know
i'm pretty loosey-goosey but you guys
are yeah
and you know what he was doing he was
just trying to show he was trying to
show off to his
to his daddy rogan that he could do
crowd work yeah and he was trying to be
like oh yeah covered right we're all
scared of that and then rogan's like nah
but it's not really that big of a deal
yeah no but it's not that big a deal
it's like just repeats or whatever
like roger can veer brendan shaw's
opinions away from whatever
based on just being rogan it's like yeah
man i was worried i'm like these people
are making out a show i'm like you
[ __ ] people crazy
you know like i wouldn't do that yeah
but it's not that bad yeah but it's not
that bad
i like want to yell at you for being
irresponsible and for killing my grandma
kevin hart's so much smarter than me
because he got it and then now
[ __ ] it brendan the microphone stand is
so much smarter than you
at least you're taller there's that
you sound like his mom trying to make
him feel better yeah
this is okay job you're taller than that
little guy who cares about that little
[ __ ]
bleep his mom's also horribly racist
she doesn't like his new co-host about
six months later like
hey i did have it a few months ago and i
was like all right honey i tried to
watch your podcast the other day it was
like a zoo exhibit mom please
the love of god i was your old co-host i
liked him
brian was such a sweet boy he had honest
eyes
like well you didn't know brian yeah you
were like
while you had it you announced it the
day i got like hey you got cove and
i have a friend who got it and doesn't
joey lit you up
well joey was lit and lightened me up
for going and doing that show and using
joe
oh wait so oh so joey was making wait so
joey diaz is making fun of people for
doing shows is that what it is i mean
i'm trying to follow this is that
correct i'm assuming
lighten me up for going and doing that
show in houston joe rogan why you're
going to houston
what the [ __ ] you doing you want to
catch that [ __ ] gonna catch that [ __ ]
give it give it to your [ __ ] friends
joey come on well he's worried about
getting it you know and he should be
with it was his health and you know his
stature he should be
you know because i have a uh family
friend my mother-in-law's best friends
their son got he's 22
you know out of shape but he passed away
from it whoa yeah he's 22.
whoa what are you [ __ ] keanu reeves
whoa
excellent 22.
so there's like those outliers how out
of shape is it
you know pretty you know not not like
obese probably 510
280 290. that's not obese i mean that's
obese
but i'm saying he's not like you know
he's not on tlc 600 pound life or
nothing
that's so that's morbidly obesity yeah
that's he's a hundred pounds overweight
yeah he's
he's heavy yeah [ __ ] though 22.
22. 20 heartbreaking that's what was
that's what's such a bummer man it's
like i mean he actually crashed his
motorcycle into the side of a walmart
but he had coveted
yeah he was going to get his
prescription
we have such a problem with obesity in
this country and poor diet
and that is the number one comorbidity
factor apparently for covides
is being overweight should be a wake-up
call get in shape
jesus christ it should be but you know
i've had overweight people on the
podcast i'm like you do anything about i
can't wait for the vaccine like what
about
now what about now can you imagine
having [ __ ] going on rogan showing
him talking down to you
regardless of who you are about your
weight no less
that's like something [ __ ] shut up
it's like isn't this something my
grandmother should be doing i mean yeah
shut the [ __ ] up this thing
joe rogan finger wagging people is
hilarious
you used to host a show where people
would eat scorpions
like shut the [ __ ] up you know what i
mean you you announce people getting cte
you've announced fights where brendan
chav has gotten brain damage
yeah so shut up joe seriously shut up
i went to tim dylan's house to pick him
up because he's co-hosting king and
sting with me
i go to pick him up because he lives
pretty close to me just come in check
out the new pad man
we go into this room and there's workout
equipment he goes so here's my
elliptical that i stare at every morning
there's my treadmill that i like to take
you know it's funnier than tim dillon
jokes
brandon shop telling you tim dillon
jokes
all right this this is my uh this is my
treadmill i like to stare at it and
[ __ ] make the same hack joke about
jesus maxwell over and over again
because i'm a [ __ ] one-note [ __ ]
so one trick pony
that's my that's my costume that looks
like jeffrey epstein's temple
remember that remember that bit brendan
hey brendan
remember that bit i did wear a dress
yeah i remember